Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill bird.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
September 5th,
2016 what's going on now?
Why?
Yeah.
Uh,
sorry,
the podcast is so late today.
Uh,
that's a lie.
I'm not sorry.
I'm full is what I am.
I went to a Labor Day party,
you know,
I had to make a fucking pie,
it's what I do.
They go,
hey,
you know,
bring something,
do this,
do that,
blah,
blah.
And I said,
Hi man,
I'll fucking,
I'll bring 'em.
I'll make a fucking pie.
And uh,
yeah,
I was doing that this morning and then the thing started at noon and I went over
there and uh,
had been doing so well with my diet last week.
I W I told you it was almost one 90.
It was 189.8 I need to get down to a buck 71 72 for my special on October 21st.
So I stepped on the scale yesterday and die even though the way in was,
uh,
for Tuesday.
By Tuesday I wanted to be down to one 86.
But I was a one 85.6 by Sunday.
So the first week you always do a big drop.
You can drop like three,
four pounds just because your body so fucking shocked.
Like,
Oh my God,
Salad,
what the hell is this?
You know,
and you throw a little bit of cardio when it you can drop.
But now this week,
this week is the week you bought my body goes like,
oh,
so we're doing this now.
Okay.
And then,
then it starts to slow down.
So,
um,
I really got to go hard.
So I got down to one 86,
one 85.6 made it by four ounces.
And um,
so next week I gotta be one 83.
That's it.
I just keep going.
One eight,
three one 81 77,
one 74,
one 71 and then I should have like a week to go.
And as long as I'm not a fucking moron,
um,
I won't look like fucking belly fat,
tits,
all my special in between specials,
you know,
what are you going to do?
But yeah,
that's one of the good things about doing a special every,
every,
every two years.
Man,
I get in shape.
So anyways,
I went to this party today and it was just like,
ah,
so fucking late.
Everything laid out right.
And then in the other room they had the salads and that's,
if I saw those I would've gone for him cause I was in such a good head space.
I had my eggs with my fucking oatmeal,
I had a grapefruit for fucking snack on my body was not,
was just like,
well good,
well good.
Well not craving sugar,
not crave and salt.
And I went in there,
the salads were in the other Roman right out in the open.
They had,
they had burgers,
they had dogs,
they had a Nacho making machine and old freckles hit it.
Dow.
I hit every gate and every station.
Yeah.
What in there?
Like ric flair.
Woo.
Just fucking ate them all stead voice in the back of your head,
sadly.
What are you doing?
Stop.
And I just couldn't stop.
What do you want?
Something to drink?
You know,
we got waters,
we've got beer.
We got over here,
what do you want?
What do you want us?
And I'm thinking,
drink of water.
My mouth just goes,
ah,
yeah,
try a beer.
So I had a beer,
then I had a root beer.
Then I had a little this banana cream pie.
Then of course I had to cut no my Pi because nobody was fucking eaten it.
That happens a lot,
by the way.
You know there's that thing when you become an adult and you've just complete,
you've completely lost all sense of who the fuck you are.
You know you're in a relationship.
You just fucking busy.
24 seven you got bills,
your kitchen's fucked up.
You know what I mean?
You don't even know what you're doing anymore.
You're putting on weight.
The one thing that you have as a fucking adult is that you go to a party,
you make some food,
and you just sit there hoping somebody's going to eat it.
Say It's good and validates your fucking existence.
You know nobody,
nobody dug into the pie.
And then there's,
then there's tricks.
There's tricks.
What you do is when nobody's looking,
you dig into your own shit,
right?
You're trying to position to a place where other people could see it.
You know,
when you dig into your own pie or your own fucking souffle,
whatever the fuck he made.
Right.
Hoping that,
you know,
it's like when you're at an auction,
and you're selling a car,
nobody's bidding on it.
You know,
there are people that will actually bid on their own car trying to get people
going.
Did your prime the pump,
you're playing a little fucker.
Nah.
Yeah.
You playing little gambling.
Oh,
I'm laying it down.
That's how fucking,
how much I ate today.
Lay it down on the fucking floor like a God damn freckled dog.
Um,
yeah,
so then people finally dug into it.
A cross was great as always,
but I don't know if the,
if the blueberries weren't worth fucking right or if I didn't use enough sugar.
You know,
this one called for like lemon zest.
I felt like they should've been lemon juice in there.
There was just way too fucking tart though.
So I guess the lemon juice wouldn't have helped.
It needed something else.
So I got to tell you,
it needs something else.
Oh,
you should've seen the pie crust though.
The whole upstairs,
downstairs.
You know anybody can,
you know the downstairs one is hard enough when we tried to make that top pie
crust to meet the other one.
Oh that is a shit show.
That is a fucking shit show waiting to happen the first few times I made it
there would always like split at the top and then you just,
you want it to be totally smooth,
right?
Cause you can't peek if you fuck up the bottom and no one sees it because you've
got to fill in.
But if you fuck up the top one that some people know if you're an expert or
you're intermediate or you suck.
And this one actually came out great.
And uh,
and then of course the feeling wasn't that good.
But uh,
if you had a little scoop of ice cream with that,
it was fine.
So embarrassing.
I had to go fucking eat my own pie.
No,
actually I mentioned it to the host and it was like,
which one's your made you made the blueberry and then he sat down.
He just fucking had it just because I was bringing it up.
He knew it.
I was like the fucking,
you know,
I was like the CIC without the date on prom night.
He felt bad.
That's what it was.
It was a sympathy fucking pie.
Slice of pie yards is too fucking weird.
Now talking about pie and ladies,
what do you want from me?
I'm fucking full.
So anyways,
I hope you guys had a great Labor Day weekend.
Um,
I can't believe it's already football season,
just being away for the last month.
It was great.
I missed one whole month of dog day baseball.
Now all of a sudden baseball's interesting to me.
The Red Sox to fucking read sharks at two games out.
I could probably only name one person on the team.
I know it's big.
Poppie's last fucking year.
It's his last month.
I know.
Once he goes,
I don't think I know anybody on the team.
Okay.
We had the pant at third base,
but I don't even know if he's around anymore.
I think he just left.
He just sorta aid is way out of baseball.
It's very unfortunate thing.
Um,
fucking hilarious to me though,
you know,
cause I didn't pay him.
That's funny to me that he finally got all that fucking money.
He was like,
you know what,
my whole life I was,
I've been broke and I had to eat ramen noodles and all that.
Now they just paid me enough money,
even if I never play again,
fuck this.
And he just goes out each house down.
But um,
I didn't even know that was fuck,
I'm so out of the loop over here.
I didn't even realize that it was a college football season and I was driving
down the highway,
you know,
I was driving,
I was going to go fly and um,
I just saw in the billboard,
so USC,
Alabama,
and I get the fuck Outta here.
USC and Alabama.
Those are two teams that I have rooted against Alabama.
Just lately,
once I jumped on Ellis shoes bandwagon,
of course after they won a national championship and that's when I decided to
jump on when I first moved out here and,
uh,
finally had time to watch college football and still do a set at night.
Uh,
but I've been rooting against USC forever because I was a Notre Dame fan growing
up.
And,
um,
I don't know.
It just says,
see,
I don't know what it was.
They were just,
were,
were I always root against like the best team saying like everybody roots
against the Patriots.
I get it.
You know what I mean?
I know you think were cheaters.
Yeah,
yeah.
Whatever.
Go Watch some of that Oakland Raiders Shit that hit on Lynn Swann where he just
fucking want even given all of that,
got all of that guys hits whatever his fucking name was.
Can't remember his fucking name.
He's like,
yeah,
we used to intimidate people.
It's like you're,
you're just punching someone when they're not looking in the side of the fucking
head.
Um,
anyways.
Anyways,
forget about having steroids delivered to your wife.
Um,
but anyways,
so I've always rooted against teams like that.
And uh,
back when they had Charles White,
right through Marcus Allen and everything,
I used to always rooted against those guys.
And,
uh,
and of course lately I've been rooting against Alabama for the last five,
six years just because it's fun.
And,
um,
now they're both playing each other and I was just like,
who the fuck am I going to root for?
So watch the beginning of the game and you know,
this show in the highlight of USC coming out,
like do a bunch of craze dogs right at the end of a fucking you one of those
backyard leash things,
you know,
clothes wired that they're wrong.
Then I'm like,
these guys are ramped up.
They're not afraid of the big stage.
They're ready to go.
This is going to be a game.
And like for the first couple of USC possessions,
you know,
they sack the quarterback,
they up down the field,
they throw little field goal action.
Then they fucking threw that state,
try to that fucking sweep Jesus.
Who the fuck is that?
Cornerback Humphrey,
that guy
somebody been at and by somebody I mean us,
we bet a draft.
That guy,
I think he's up for next season.
Sorry,
typing in the pot,
the password ever.
So slowly and there we go.
Marlin Humphrey,
Jesus Christ.
What a fucking hit.
He came out of nowhere.
They will run in the sweep and I was sitting in Hong gone,
you can't do this against Alabama.
They're going to string it out.
And then the guy tries to cut back inside.
He gets had made me about back outside there,
Fred.
Okay.
Oh,
we took the helmet.
Well sorry.
Blown out years and he took the fucking helmet right out of the Goddamn Shit.
I'm surprised they didn't call it helmet,
the helmet because you get mostly his chest.
And um,
then my wife was downstairs,
you know,
I hadn't spent any time with or whatever and I was just like,
all right,
I'm taping this game.
I'll come back to this in a minute.
And uh,
you know,
whatever.
Went downstairs,
couple hours,
hung out with my wife.
She watched one horrific fucking show after another.
Oh my God.
The horror,
the horror of what she was watching.
She finally shut it off and then we started watching this,
this series on Netflix.
It was something about these chefs and was all these,
these French cooks.
And uh,
it was great to hear the French language cause I kind of stopped once again,
I was picking up,
you know,
little phrases here or there that made me feel good in these fucking,
these chefs were incredible.
We watched like two or three episodes of it.
Of course,
I don't know what the name of it is,
but it made me want to live in Paris for like fucking three months,
four months,
five,
whatever it would take just to get kind of passable and take a pastry making
class.
I know that sounds like the stupidest thing ever,
but this fucking guy,
he takes like an apple and he was going like this guy was an artist.
He was just sitting there going like,
you know,
I was so sick of making all these fucking thing.
Hey,
I had to come up with some new
thing to do with an apple.
And He fucking just imagine if you just kept peeling a thing,
right?
If you would just peeling the skin off but you just kept going all the way down
to the core.
He did that and it was all one piece you did with some hand crank thing and he
said,
I wanted to make a rose out of out of an apple and he somehow did it and turn it
into a dessert.
You fucking chopped a duck in a,
in a chicken in half.
And he sewed them together,
which was very naziesque slash American horror story that kind of creep me out.
And then of course they had to show how they fucking,
they were cooking lobsters,
live lobsters over an open flame.
Could I can show you guys a question.
What,
what are the lobster ever do to us?
Okay.
Every other animal has the decency of being dead before we fucking least in this
country.
I know other countries,
they got fucking Matt maggots running around their apple jacks for extra
protein.
Know that's like us putting way potter into our shakes.
They put like fucking bugs and stuff,
you know what I mean?
Okay.
Like they actually excited that there's bugs in their house.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
it's like the food truck came by,
but in our country,
right.
Like that stuff is like,
it's looked down upon every,
you know,
that's,
that's the great thing about traveling.
You know what I mean?
You just sit there,
oh,
toe cheese.
Oh,
that's a delicacy over here.
You know,
that's one of the wonderful things.
Puts a little spring in your step.
A little twinkle in your eyes.
So anyways,
I'm watching this fucking lunatic and um,
for the life of me,
I don't know why they just can't.
At least just,
can you just fucking,
I dunno.
Can they make it like a little lobster hammer and just fucking knock,
knock it out.
At least does it have to be squirming on the flame and you have to keep telling
me that it doesn't feel pain.
It doesn't have a central nervous system.
Whatever the fuck they try to say.
It's just like,
like what?
It's like an Amoeba.
It isn't.
Okay.
The fucking things got eyeballs and shit.
It's walking around.
It's got its little tentacles,
what we call it.
Those,
those big fucking thing's coming out.
They can see it,
breathes,
you gotta have paid.
That's part of survival,
right.
Which shows a way to shut it off.
You know what I mean?
Especially with people getting like tortured to death.
You could just shut it off and the guys saw in your hand off,
you're like,
oh yeah,
he's that.
Was that what you're doing?
Um,
Jesus,
I'm all over the map.
I was talking about La fucking Nadella.
She always talking about Alabama USC.
Now where the hell am I?
So anyways,
the guy got sick of talking about a week after a while,
he just got sick of the blood of all the animals in the,
and he got three stars over and um,
okay.
In France in three stars is the highest you can get,
which is so fucking Parisian.
You know what I mean?
There's so fucking understated and classy.
I hate to say it is American,
but they really are.
They really earned their snooty fucking behavior over there.
The people that style their clothes,
that they crush it.
You know what I mean?
You know Mr t,
we got himself a gold chain and there was this like,
you know what?
One isn't enough.
Let me get fucking 9,000 of them and hang around.
They're the exact opposite of that.
They got like all mode muted colors and then Bam,
a sick ass pair of shoes or a hat or the ladies with their bags,
just fucking class.
It's not like,
you know,
it's not like as loud Americans,
you know?
But it's good to be loud sometimes.
You know?
I like a fucking muscle car like anybody else.
I like it.
I like the Wendy's triple fucking cheeseburger.
I have it tell you guys that time where I was standing in the line with me and I
just kept making fun of the triple cheeseburger at Wendy's,
just kept going.
Who the fuck would order a triple cheeseburger?
I just kept going,
come get her book and let me get a triple cheeseburger the book.
And I just kept doing their triple cheeseburger and I just kept saying it.
When I went up there,
I wasn't thinking and I just said triple cheeseburger.
And then after I said it,
I was just like,
well fuck it.
I'll,
I'll eat it.
And you know what?
It's delicious.
And I still think about it.
I still remember where I got it.
I was on like Lexington Avenue in New York City or maybe second hour.
I was on the east side was the last time I had a triple cheeseburger.
Fuck,
that was like seven,
eight years ago,
nine years ago,
10 maybe.
Um,
anyway,
so the guy just decides out of the fucking blue,
this guy decides is French chef.
I'm back,
I'm back in Paris again.
Okay.
He just decides he's not going to fucking,
he's sick.
All the blood,
gutting all the animals and all of that shit.
He doesn't want to do it anymore.
He's just going to go 100% vegetarian at his restaurant and he might lose his
stars
in Parisian cuisine or in France.
You lose your stars.
It's like,
it's,
it's like losing your soul.
And he just made the decision.
He actually went to the board of the people that gives them the stars and just
said,
look,
I'm taking meat off the menu.
I'm just going all vegetarian.
And they were like,
are you Outta your mind?
And he goes,
no,
I'm not.
I'm just doing vegetarian shit.
And uh,
you know,
do what you want with my stars.
You know,
and I'll leave it at that.
And then you watch the rest of the fuck.
Well,
mostly not going to watch it,
right?
Well,
if then fast forward to the next five minutes because they're going to ruin it
for you.
So he ends up doing it.
He fucking crushes it and he retains his stars.
But then eventually he did bring the meat back because it's such a big fucking
deal.
But he also learned how to crush it with the fucking vegetables.
But this guy was like a lunatic man.
Like he,
he was like a pro prolific comedian where he just,
once he had his hour a killer shit,
he just,
he just flushed it down.
The toilet shot a special.
Now moving onto the next one.
You know,
I don't know.
I was pretty amazed by it.
But let's get back to,
fuck.
I know I'm all over the place.
Okay.
My sugar is through the fucking roof right now.
My mouth is dried out.
My body's like,
what the fuck?
And after it.
Now,
not only do I have my body in this level of shock,
I'm actually in about a two hours.
When my stomach's settles,
I'm going to do my 45 minutes of cardio.
I'm just gonna try to like salvage some sort of,
you know,
like if this was a football game,
I'm down by 20.
But like,
I'm just at this point,
like I don't want to lose by 25.
That's,
that's all I'm doing here.
Okay.
MMM.
And then I go on the fucking road,
right?
I got a Gig in long island on Wednesday,
and then Charlotte and then
no,
Columbia,
Charleston,
South Carolina,
and then Charlotte.
And then I got two cities,
Richmond and,
uh,
somewhere else in fucking Virginia.
And then I come back on Monday.
So this is going to be the big test and I'm on the road.
All right.
I gotta make sure I'm not going to be fucking eating like an asshole.
I got to find elliptical machines and four or five different goddamn cities and
you know,
every fucking hotel.
Do you have a gym?
Yeah,
we have a gym.
It's on the fourth floor.
And you go down there and they have like a fucking treadmill that they bought in
like 1978.
You know,
if there's a picture like bill Rogers on the side,
he won the Boston marathon a couple of times in the late 70.
[inaudible] you know,
back when,
uh,
I think it was before Kenyans were to run in marathons because once they let the
Kenyans run,
that's,
that's been it.
I can't remember the last time there was like Angel Salazar,
I think that was his name at Bill Rogers.
And they would fucking win every one of them,
it seemed.
And then what's the Kenyans came and then that was,
it was fucking over talking like a 36 year run at this point.
So anyways,
um,
I'm finally going to finish this so that I have five finally.
Um,
oh,
I went down to the comedy store and I did a,
I did a set.
So I was just like,
did anybody see the end?
What was the final,
all the Alabama SC game?
I shut it off when USC was up three to nothing.
So he told me it was like 51 to six Alabama came back in the old right there,
Fred.
So I,
uh,
I watched some of the highlights,
but I'm telling you that fucking cornerback,
Jesus Christ,
he would make a great Pittsburgh stealer.
He would make a great New York giant.
You know,
there's teams that just always have great defenses.
if we sign them,
we'll keep them right until he makes a pro bowl.
And then we'll let him go and then I'll end up going to the jets or somebody,
the bills or the dolphins.
Not only will you let him go,
he'll sign in our fucking division.
But I hope we get that guy or get somebody like,
I mean,
granted what he did was at the collegiate level,
but it was really impressive.
He shut down.
Um,
whoever uscs guy was,
I don't know shit about college football the same way.
I don't know shit about fucking formula one racing.
I don't know shit.
I just talk.
All right.
Um,
he shut down like I guess their Dez Bryant Level Guy.
Guy had one catch for like nine yards from the third quarter.
He intercepted a pass for like,
uh,
for a touchdown.
I mean like he just,
it was it you just looking at the guy and then he came up and shut down the
fucking sweep,
put that guy on his ass.
And that's the kind of guy that's the kind of guy you're white up.
Jesus.
He's a comedian.
He knows how to build a football team now.
Anyways.
Do you guys watch any of the Formula One race and I've gotten any you guys into
that shit?
Uh,
what's his face?
Lewis Hamilton.
I don't understand.
How do they fuck up the start of the race?
The guys in the pole position and all of a sudden they turn into like these
funds.
Do you ever like learn how to,
the first time you learned to drive a clutch,
you let out the clutch too fast.
You don't give it enough throttle and you'll stall.
It's like they do that except in front of a zillion people around the world
watching it.
This guy was in first place by the time they got to the first turn,
Lewis Hamilton,
the champion.
Okay.
The fucking guy was in sixth place.
Nico Rosberg took the lead a never gave it back,
but it was a great fucking race.
Um,
Jesus Christ,
the Italian fans were going crazy.
Fucking crazy.
Just willing Ferrari to get to the podium,
which is the first three.
And that sport,
which I think also in the Olympics,
they're all starting to run together.
They,
uh,
they got third and fourth place.
So they made the podium and those Italian people went fucking bananas.
Fuck.
Even if the announcers are going,
can you imagine if they actually won?
Uh,
but it was a,
it was a great race.
Whatever.
I still don't understand the soft super soft,
the medium tires,
that's all the one I'm really starting to understand is that when you pit and
what tire you are using evidently is like one of the biggest things in the race
because I don't know whoever,
whoever fucking makes it into the first turn first they win the race.
Every fucking race I've watched,
it's,
it's a race from the starting line to the first turn.
Whoever comes out in front that's fucking it over.
You've won the race and then the,
then the whole battles for second through fucking sixth,
and then he's holding a super soft about this.
You know,
Ricky Bobby's on the mediums now.
Those are a little bit heavier,
but he's going to be able to stay out there for another 23 fucking laps or
whatever the hell's going on.
And I really try to pay attention to figure out what's going on,
but I can't quite figure it out.
I guess with the super soft,
they tear up quicker because I know what that one fucking car,
what the hell is it called?
The,
the,
uh,
the one that,
the pet fastest production car,
it basically can go like 220 miles an hour.
But you know,
it can drive like 220 miles an hour.
But at that speed you'll literally where the tires off in like 15 minutes.
But that's okay because you run out of gas and like 13,
how fucked up is that?
So maybe the super soft.
So I like that if anybody has any information because I'm going to keep fucking
watching it.
They're in Singapore next,
they're done with Europe,
they're going over to Singapore now,
which I'm looking forward to because I'm,
you know,
when they go start traveling around Southeast Asia and they're going to like
Japan and all that,
like that's a part of the world that really interests me because,
you know,
I've,
I've only,
I went there one time but it was only for a few days.
And uh,
yeah,
I don't know.
That's one of the cool things that,
one of the things I really do enjoy about that sport.
And I guess I wish I could get into soccer man,
cause I know that they go all the way around the world.
You know,
maybe that's why I let people are good at geography.
They watch actual world sports,
you know?
And if you actually win a world championship,
you competed against the fucking world.
Does that make sense?
All right,
I'm going to shut up now.
Let's,
uh,
while I'm out,
I'm going to read some advertising.
Um,
I hope this podcast is making sense by the way,
because,
uh,
I literally feel like I could take a Thanksgiving Day nap right now.
I don't know what the fuck I was doing.
I had a burger,
I had a fucking hot dog,
Nachos,
beer,
root beer,
trying to go through my head.
I just lost count.
I just was like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Oh,
Billy fat.
It's a all right dollar shave club,
everybody.
I was like Bluto in animal house.
All right.
Dollar Shave Club.
Okay
guys,
I appreciate
you listening to the show.
And,
uh,
and wanted to do something to thank you.
So I contacted my friends@dollarshaveclub.com and arrange for them to give new
net members a month of the executive razor for free just for buying a tube of Dr
cabbies.
Easy shave butter.
I did nothing like that.
I've never talked to those people.
I would not call them.
Yeah.
Why do they write shit like that?
Do you guys really whoa.
Well look at Billy's really going the extra mile for us.
Whatever the fuck they they give you.
They made that decision and then I just read it.
Um,
evidently I'm super excited that they're doing it for you.
Now let me remind you why me.
Millions of others have joined as me as a proud member of the club,
not a member of the club.
Anything that involves going online and registering for shit,
I,
I won't do it.
I won't do it because I can't figure it out.
It takes too long.
I have to call somebody.
It's like,
it's like dad,
who wants to be a millionaire,
right.
You know what I mean?
One of the worst fucking shows of all time.
Who wants to be a millionaire?
And then like the people were so fucking dumb on that they had to call their
friends like halfway through.
Like,
can you help me out?
You know what I mean?
That doesn't happen on jeopardy.
That doesn't even happen on fucking wheel of fortune prices.
Right.
You know,
you kind of look out to the crowd and everyday
Zigler,
I don't know.
Anyways,
um,
let's get back to this shit here.
All right,
you,
you get the first class,
you get a first class shave when you use the executive blade,
and that's without even hurting your wallet.
And when you use the executive with their Dr Carver's shave butter,
the blade gently glides across for the smoothest shave.
Yeah,
Abba shave butter isn't your average shave cream.
Ah,
what's made out a death of deals and baby buts.
It's a unique conditioning formula with high quality natural ingredients,
leaving your skin unbelievably soft and smooth.
Now's a great time to,
to join dollar shave club.
New members who buy a tube of shave butter.
Get a month of the executive razor for absolutely free.
Take advantage of this special offer today.
It's available by going to dollar shave club.com/burr that's dollar shave
club.com/ [inaudible]
oh look who's back everybody.
But Oh boop,
boop me undies.
Mandy's making up blueberry Pie Badu due to me undies.
Biondi keep eating and you don't know why and all of a sudden your balls are at
your feet,
but they feel real comfortable.
And that's real neat.
Cause when you were fucking me undies.
Yeah,
they fucking put your nuts in a hammock or maybe your twat.
Now when Pfos,
those beef fucking cartons,
all right,
Mandy's,
whether you're wearing a suit
or sweats,
you spend almost 24 hours a day in your underwear.
But instead of making a statement like Superman's tights under his everyday
clothes,
your,
your underwear is probably boring me.
UNDIES is here to help change that.
Um,
please include modal.
All right.
Every player of me undies is made with from sustainable sources.
Madell of fabric that's twice as soft as cotton.
Nothing can describe the fit and feel of me undies.
You got to feel it up against your balls.
You,
yourself.
I could try to explain it to you.
Okay.
But it'd be like somebody trying to explain that first hit of heroin.
You know what I mean?
You know,
they always say it's like being held in your mother's arms.
It's like being held in your mother's arms.
Well,
what if you came from a family and they weren't huggers?
You know what I mean?
Now you might as well just be saying like,
it's like the first time you drive a Lamborghini.
I never drove.
Uh,
once you try them on,
you understand why they're called the world's world's world's most comfortable
underwear.
And if you don't love your first pair of me undies,
they're free.
No questions asked me.
UNDIES has dozens of,
of course it is.
What are you going to give it back to them?
You already walked around farting in it and God knows what else.
Shook your dick off.
And then the rest of it dried up in there.
No questions asked me.
And he says dozens of styles and limited edition prints to help you make a
statement with your underwear,
whether anyone can see them or not.
Remember,
Superman,
a shipping is free and the U S and Canada.
And you can save up to $8 a pair with the [inaudible] subscription plan.
Get the subscription or a single pair.
Uh,
you get 20% off your first order when you go to [inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com slash burr for 20% off your first order.
[inaudible] dot com slash bar how many more fucking things we got here?
Three.
Four.
No,
no,
no.
Those are the reeds.
All right,
two more.
Two more.
Sorry everybody.
Sorry.
It's the fucking sugar.
Um,
or blue apron.
Everyone.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Speaking of food,
you know,
not all ingredients are created equal.
Okay?
Jesus,
separate but equal is very racist here.
This is for food,
Huh?
Uh,
this is like reverse America.
Fresh,
high quality ingredients taste better and better and are better for you.
So it's important to know where your food comes from.
Talk about your personal experiences with blue apron.
Oh,
I've never used it.
So you know,
it looks fucking great on the commercial.
Jesus Christ,
they got a good commercial.
You see that one where the guy's got the Thai noodles?
Fucking unbelievable.
Then at the end they show like the silhouette and you could see is get a blow
Joe.
It's just like,
wow,
these guys are really,
they're really claiming a lot with this food.
Uh
Oh,
maybe it fell asleep watching cinema,
I don't know.
Uh,
for less than dollars per meal,
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes along with pre,
pre portioned ingredients to make delicious home cooked meals.
Blue Apron knows that when you cook with incredible ingredients,
you make incredible meals.
Well,
yeah,
unless you fuck it up.
So they set the highest quality standards for their community of artisanal
suppliers,
family run farms,
fisheries and ranchers,
whether it's Japanese ramen noodles,
wild caught Alaskan salmon are heirloom tomatoes.
Blue Apron is bringing you the best.
New recipes are created weekly and are not repeated within a year.
That's incredible.
Choose your meals from,
from a variety of recipes,
or let blue apron culinary team surprise.
You know,
if I had a fucking marketing bone in my body,
also,
if I wasn't on the road up until my special,
I would just eat fucking blue apron every God damn night and workout,
right?
I tell him to send me this shit for free.
I'll keep hyping them and I'll give them the credit for me losing weight,
you know,
rather than I'm going down to the elliptical every day,
sweating like a fucking junkie in a holding cell.
Uh,
anyways,
customize your recipes each week based on your preferences.
Choose delivery options to fit your needs.
There's no weekly commitment,
so you only get deliveries when you want them,
which is great.
Check out this week's menu and get your first three meals for free with free
shipping by going to blue apron.com/burr.
Uh,
you'll love how good it feels and tastes to create incredible home cooked meals
with blue apron.
So don't wait.
That's blue apron.com/bar blue apron,
a better way to cook.
You know,
that really is,
that really is one of the better fucking advertisers we have.
MMM.
If I was a younger man and I wasn't a road dog,
I swear to God I could really fucking,
okay.
I'm actually thinking about doing it cause you know,
I would love to learn to cook some of that Asian Shit.
You know,
I'm always,
I'm always too intimidated.
Like there's,
there's all these places out here,
Korea town,
Thai town,
Chinatown,
all of that.
And I always look into their markets and everything and I'm just so fucking
intimidated because I don't know what any of this shit is,
you know?
I don't know what the fuck's going on.
You know?
Then when you were in like Chinatown and like a San Francisco,
they got all this stuff,
but then you see like a whole duck just hanging by his neck and he's just like,
oh my God.
You know,
you start thinking about Vietnam movies that you watched and you know the deer
hunter and then all of a sudden you'd start sweating and you get out of there
and next thing you know you're eating a cheeseburger when you should've got a
burrito.
You're in San Francisco.
All right,
score big everybody.
Okay.
You're paying too much for tickets between all the markups.
Last minute convenient charges,
even printing home fees,
you end up paying court side prices for nose bleed,
bleed,
bleed seats.
Sorry.
Scorebig is here to change that.
Guys,
I don't know about this company to be honest with you.
I think this is just another fucking scalping site.
Yeah.
You know,
I think what they're claiming they end up doing.
Did you know that 40% of all live event tickets go on?
Sold that?
No,
that's not true.
That is not true.
That isn't.
I know what happens is,
is you fucking assholes go and you buy them up and act like you got him.
Something happens.
I Dunno.
This is so fucking thick.
Seems fishy to me.
And did you know there's a place to get seats at huge savings.
It's called ScoreBig.
Scorebig works directly with your favorite teams and artists to get oh good.
So they get a cut and artists to get their unsold seats at unpublished prices.
That's bullshit.
People's scalp tickets to my shows all the fucking time.
And fans end up yelling at me and I'm not,
I don't make any money off of that.
I get that all the time.
Dude,
you're funny.
You're not this funny.
And then I look and I go,
Jesus Christ,
and I called my age and go,
what the fuck are we charging us money for?
He's like,
we're not doing that.
Those are scalpers.
I don't know,
maybe score,
maybe score big on the level.
I'm gonna have to do a little research here.
Only with score big.
Can you name a ticket price?
It'd be guaranteed to pay below box office up to 60% off.
Now see right there,
they're talking some shit there below box office,
self box offices,
a hundred bucks,
you know?
Then you should be getting it for 40,
right?
Or at least under whatever the fuck that,
because they say up to 60% off.
All right,
here's what you do.
One,
go to score big.com or download the new score,
big APP on your iPhone and find the events and tickets.
Uh,
the seats you want to make an offer.
It was score Biggs name a ticket price feature three,
get an instant answer and save up to 60% on your tickets.
Ah,
maybe they not,
they're not that bad.
Name any fees,
never any fees and shipping is always free.
You can count on unbeatable prices and great seats and when you're in grade
seats,
you actually enjoy the game or the show.
All the more.
Next thing you.
Yeah,
it's just stand down there taking a fucking selfie a next time you go see any
game or a show,
go to score big first and see how much you can save for the easiest way to save
on tickets.
Download the new score.
Big App for your iPhone.
Enter Promo Code [inaudible] at checkout and you'll save an extra $20 off your
first ticket price.
No iPhone,
no problem.
Get $20 off online to@scorebig.com that's [inaudible] dot com promo code
[inaudible] score,
big.com Promo Code Burr.
That's it,
right?
Dakota access pipeline.
Oh,
okay.
That's,
that's part of a question.
I will sit in their reading.
They're like,
what the fuck is that thought?
That was like the end of the copy.
I think that was some code to save money.
It's somebody question.
All right,
hang on a second.
Jesus Christ.
Okay,
let,
let's,
let's read some questions here for the week,
shall we?
Um,
all right.
By the way,
as I mentioned,
everybody a Wednesday,
I'm going to be back out in Long Island.
This is the makeup date for that show that I had to cancel because of the
snowstorm.
Whenever the hell that was back in January.
I'm doing two shows out there.
Um,
with Vinnie.
Mark,
one of my great friends,
one of the nicest people I ever met in show business when I first started.
Uh,
it was very nice to me.
did I ever tell you guys that,
oh my God,
like this story,
there's very few times in my career where
I actually,
when I was on my way starting out that I actually thought about quitting.
MMM.
I remember the,
for the first time I was still living at home with my parents and there was some
big football game on like BC was playing Notre Dame.
Okay.
And,
uh,
I had a Gig in some hell room down and,
um,
Donna Rhode Island,
and never forget it.
This,
this always makes me have a panic attack because I said to my brother,
I go,
I don't know man,
you guys are hanging out.
You're watching the game.
Uh,
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't feel like going.
And my brother said,
uh,
he said,
you should go.
And I ended up going down there and I had a good set.
And then I never had that feeling again.
And I always thought like,
what the fuck if he didn't say that,
like if I didn't go when I be that guy who started and just quit,
you know,
so anyways,
the next time I had it,
because I can,
I've only had it like two or three times in my career.
The next time I had it.
Um,
I definitely believe me had times where I,
I thought I made the wrong decision,
or I was just sitting there going like,
am I going to be the guy who just never fucking sells a ticket?
Am I going to be that guy?
You know?
And I remember going back to the fucking hotels.
Okay.
I'm in one night in particular going back to the hotel and I wrap the pillow
around my head,
like ear muffs,
you know,
I was telling this story to Marin the other night.
He was laughing.
I said it wrapped it around my head,
like ear must run the back of my head trying to block out the negativity,
you know,
which is still because it was coming from inside my brain.
Um,
but uh,
when I first met Vinnie mark,
I just moved to New York and I got my first manager and he hooked me up with
this Gig.
It was somewhere out in the,
it was either,
I want to say it was either Brooklyn or long island.
I can't remember what,
I can't remember if it was pips.
I don't think it was because the green room wasn't like a comedy club,
Green Room.
It was just this,
it was a shit hole.
Whatever it was.
Yeah.
It wasn't pips cause pips had like head shots and stuff does,
had no head shots.
I think pips was later.
MMM.
But I went down there,
man,
and
Vinnie was headlining.
And then this guy,
this the Middle Act was one of these guys who used to be a headliner.
He was a headliner during the 80s,
boom,
because there was,
they had more fucking rooms doing comedy than they actually had comedians that
could fucking fill it.
You know,
it's like those,
it's like the Djs now out in Vegas,
they got more Dj Romes than they have,
you know,
major known,
uh,
big name Djs that can fill them.
So they'd like just naming that price out there and that clean it up.
God bless him.
Right?
So,
uh,
this guy was living that life headlining just because it was in the middle of a
boom.
And anyways,
it all came crashing down and this guy was no longer headlining.
And during the day he was driving a bus and this guy was one of the most
negative fucking people ever.
And I showed up and I didn't know how I was too young.
I didn't know.
I didn't have like the defense shields up,
like,
yeah,
fuck this guy.
I'm not listening to this guy.
Everything that he said.
I took his law and he was basically trying to convince me to quit.
And,
uh,
what's his face while Vinny was up on stage?
This guy was just getting in my fucking ear and then the next night it had to
come back again.
And while the Middle Act was on stage,
I was just,
I was talking to Vinnies go,
man,
that guy who's saying this saying this.
And he was just really,
it was like,
man,
don't listen to that fucking guy.
And Vinnie was totally silly.
He was upbeat,
he was having a great time.
And
I dunno,
I just set up,
before I talked to Vinnie,
I was literally just sitting there like going like,
I don't know that I can do this.
Yeah.
I can't,
I can't sit and listen to like,
is this,
this is what New York comedy is.
You go do a Gig.
You know,
I was already feeling weird because I was out of Massachusetts.
Nobody talked like me anymore.
I was like this fucking little baby deer wandering around trying to figure out
where it,
where it could get stage time and um,
okay.
You know,
New York seemed like a million miles away back then.
This is the mid nineties.
I mean,
people,
I didn't even,
I hadn't even bought my first laptop yet.
Forget about even it never even been on the fucking internet as far as I
remember.
MMM,
no,
I think it had been a little bit,
I didn't.
I bought my first laptop in 1996 I remember it was like just thick as the first
flat screen TV to probably weighed just as much.
So anyways,
meaning that New York was a million miles away.
I didn't know anything about it.
And I just remember just thinking like,
if this is what every fucking weekend is going to be like in this place,
I might be moving back home.
And he was a guy once again,
just by luck,
somebody came along and fucking talk me out of whatever the hell my head was
saying.
So anyways,
all these years later,
we get to do another weekend together.
So very excited to be working with him.
Do for the rest of the tour.
Um,
Todd,
rex,
Rex,
ladies and gentlemen,
t rex,
the fucking lunatic.
Uh,
it's going to be opening for me.
I'm fucking hilarious guy.
Uh,
he's going to be going all the way through the Carolinas and a into Virginia
with me.
So a good at my work cut up.
So I probably shouldn't eat all that God damn food.
But with that,
let me,
uh,
let me do some of the reeds here for this week.
All right.
Um,
Dakota access pipeline,
whatever the fuck this means.
You definitely have my,
uh,
okay.
Peaked my interest here.
Pay High.
Bill,
I've been listening to your podcast for one and a half years.
You're a very funny comedian.
I was hoping to get your thoughts on the Dakota access pipeline.
Now,
for some reason I feel like this is some sort of jokey thing and they just
wanted to hear me say it out loud,
but I'll look it up to cota access pipeline.
Let's see what the fuck this is.
Dakota access pipeline protests in North Dakota turned violent.
All right.
When the protests not turned violent.
It's always this protestors and then the cops show up.
They,
yeah,
bye.
Take it easy.
So he got you fucking take it easy,
man.
Somebody throws a punch and then it's,
it's a fucking,
it's a bra.
All right.
Protest against the Dakota access pipeline in North Dakota.
Turned violent on Saturday,
demonstrated supporting the standing rock Sioux tribe.
Faced off with private security officers from the Dallas based engine energy
transfer partners.
Wait,
it's on native American land and they have,
and the big corporation as their own security officers.
Okay.
Is Julia Roberts already optioned this for a Oscar winning role.
She goes in and somehow figures out how to defeat the Dallas space energy
transfer partners.
A video from the scene showed security offers is threatening protesters with
dogs.
As all things consider reported,
hundreds of native Americans from tribes across the country have set up a camp
near the construction site in North Dakota.
The army corps of engineers approve the oil pipeline in July,
allowing it to run under the Missouri River,
close to the standing rock Sioux tribe reservation.
And you know what's going to happen eventually.
Yeah.
That pipeline is going to burst as they always do.
Protestors worry that the $3.80 8 million billion pipeline,
which is slated to run through four states could disturb sacred sites and effect
the reservations.
Drinking water abso-fucking-lutely if human beings are involved is always the
chance.
Second happen.
The,
the show democracy now was at the site of the protest Saturday and documented
some tense moments.
Dogs appeared to bike protestors and security guards appeared to use pepper
spray.
Warning the video below includes some fleeting explicative.
So I think I can handle this.
We're standing at the construction site of the Dakota access pipeline.
It looks like there are
please.
Yeah.
These people are not going to win.
It's just,
it's a bunch of people saying no wearing like hipster hats while people drive
bulldozers.
It's already happening.
Um,
oh yeah.
Yeah.
It looks disorganized as a bunch of different signs.
Chicken,
chicken.
Where are you still get Washington?
Can you describe what you see?
This is so nuts.
Yeah.
To come down and yell at people on bulldozers,
like I guess,
cause you want it,
you want to get the,
uh,
the attention of the media with their,
on bulldozers on the other side of a wire.
So like what,
what are you going to do?
Uh,
once protest is arrived at the construction area,
they broke down a wire fence by stepping in,
jumping on it.
Yeah.
Then of course,
immediately they're trespassing according to numerous witnesses within five
minutes to crowd of protesters estimated to be a few hundred people became
violent.
They stampeded into the construction area with horses,
dogs and vehicles.
Okay.
And it was said more.
The sheriff said it was more like a riot than a protest,
but the cops always say that,
you know,
and then the protest is always say the cops throw the first punch.
You never know who to believe.
This is like,
let's,
let's watch this.
This is like a protest to WWE.
All right,
this guy's got a cell phone.
He looks to be native American or maybe he's a appropriating their culture,
you know,
having his hair long.
Yeah.
I don't know what's going on.
There's a fucking helicopter.
Okay,
let's get to the dogs.
Water is life.
Somebody held that and it was written and it was a feather in the background.
All right.
Now who's a woman?
Oh,
this isn't gonna end.
Well,
they're going through the fence.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
somebody got nice tackle.
Nice tackle.
Oh,
now they got some dogs.
The security,
I think they just did.
They're going to Adam and square here.
They just trying to get in front of them.
Yeah.
This sounds great.
This sounds like a,
the usual big business thing that they,
I don't know anything about it.
Um,
I do feel like eventually they're going to do enough of that fracking and then
they'll fuck up all the water,
all the drinking water.
And I don't think corporations care.
I just think that'd be it.
Well then that's great.
Then there'll be no fresh water for anybody to use,
so they'll have to all go to Nestle for their fresh water.
You know,
and then we'll say that it's just still,
but it really isn't.
It's SORTA is.
And when they get sick,
the class action suit versus the money we're going to make.
Yeah.
We're not going to give a fuck.
We'll pay him off.
That'll be yet,
Eh,
uh,
I dunno.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't have any faith in anything to be honest with you.
I think we're just going to completely destroy the planet and each other.
But in the meantime,
if I could make you laugh a little bit,
do you ever at the end of Carlin's life
when people were saying he got to fucking angry,
I didn't think that.
I was just like,
yeah,
this guy's making a lot of sense to me.
It was still funny to me.
Still made sense.
I thought,
uh,
I dunno.
However he read the tea leaves,
it made sense to me.
Um,
okay.
Oh,
just about the whole way we go about fucking communicate with each other.
We just end up screaming and yelling and then we get physical and somebody hits
somebody and then I'll all hell breaks loose.
That's,
that's what happens.
It happens,
you know,
I do it.
I started discussing this election with some people the other day,
and within three minutes of me talking,
three quarters of the people walked out of the rump.
I mean that,
that's how in sufferable I am.
Is that the right word?
Um,
women's suffrage,
uh,
whatever the fuck it is.
What do I think about it?
I'm starting to get your thoughts and just go to access pipeline.
Um,
I don't know,
Dude.
There's just too many fucking people because everyone,
you know,
I love a Tesla.
I love a Prius,
Prius and all that shit,
but if you get all these cars,
then all of a sudden everybody has to plug in their car,
then that's more energy.
I know when you make electricity that,
you know,
you need machines and the machines need the oil sell.
It's just,
it's we consume is what we do and there's too many of us.
That's the fucking problem.
All these technological advances,
myths that we make are tremendous.
It's just the amount of people that have to live off of him.
That's where a,
it's like getting fat.
You know what I mean?
All fat is,
is you're,
you're,
you're taking in more calories than you're burning.
And that's kind of like what we're doing,
except we're taking more,
more than we're given back and eventually it's,
it's got to run out.
Uh,
so I think there's going to be a drastic decision at some point it's going to
have going to have to be made about the population.
You know,
it's just inevitable.
There's gay,
you know,
when there's fucking 6 billion people left.
Why did I pick that number?
I shouldn't have said that now,
but let me take a,
a more empathetic number.
Cause that's what I was thinking of.
I was only thinking Hitler.
I mean,
someone's going to have to fuck someone is going to end up doing that.
Okay.
If we could somehow all sit down and talk this out in this book,
but you just,
what you would literally have to do,
you'd literally have to try to get everybody in the world on the same page and
to see it the same way.
You know,
you had a fear of Jira.
Fucking,
you get your order a UFC event,
you get 10 people in the room.
I mean,
how many can people agree on the one place to order from?
If you put it up to a vote,
you know you're going to get the whole world to get on page.
It's somebody who's going to have to do the old right there,
Fred.
Um,
yeah,
I dunno dude.
They should,
they should
do it first voluntarily.
Like they should be all right.
This is the deal we're going to have to take out.
We got to get this number down below a billion and there's seven and a half
billion of us.
So,
uh,
we're going to get to this number no matter what.
It's like when a,
when a fucking flight is oversold and they try to get some volunteers,
you know,
I wonder if the tree huggers,
I'm a lazy tree hugger.
I love nature,
but you know,
you know,
I'm not going to go make a sign or chain myself to a sapling,
so,
you know,
I talk a good game,
but I,
I don't do any of the shit.
Right.
So what I'm wondering is if,
if they go on,
look,
we're going to get the population down below to 1,000,000,001 way or the other.
We're asking for some volunteers.
If you're willing to,
to,
uh,
walk into the wood chipper or whatever the fuck you have to do.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
we'll give a voucher
to the surviving members of your family or whatever.
I mean,
but even then,
they mean they have to,
if you're gonna,
if you're going to cut it by that much.
Um,
cause I literally think that that's what,
that's what we're going to run into.
Yeah.
And
then there's going to,
there's going to be this big fun,
like,
I think that that Bilderberg Shit,
like this is what they have to talk about going,
okay,
we have to keep the best of the best of each race,
each gender.
Yeah.
Hope that they're going to do that.
Right.
And
yeah,
and then everybody else has to go and then they to be one waiting,
wait,
we don't want to mow our own lawns.
Right?
We've got to keep some meat heads around a pick shit up.
We don't want to have to like if we kill too many people then all of a sudden we
have to build our own log cabins.
We don't want that.
So it's going to be really like,
you know,
is going to have like have like their own fucking city that we don't know about.
Right.
And everybody goes to like,
almost like Superman's hide out and everybody goes up there.
Right.
And it's enough people to keep humanity going,
but at this point you need enough people.
Do you ever see that fucking thing?
Like what would happen if all the people went away and after like I don't know
how many days,
like the nuclear reactors,
the,
uh,
they all had like the meltdowns because whatever was going on and wasn't keeping
those,
those fucking things at homer Simpson always takes home with them.
They don't keep it cool.
Jesus.
I'm way in over my head now.
Huh?
Um,
I don't know.
I'm fucking people you'd have to keep alive,
but uh,
I,
I just don't see it.
So as far as the Dakota access pipeline,
that's just one of those things where I watch it and I feel bad for the people
that live there and I am,
I don't really know enough about the other end of it.
I know that trying to make money,
but they also are also trying to keep 300 million people living at a certain
standard of living.
Right.
Aren't they here in this country?
I have no fucking idea.
All right.
Jesus Christ that,
that literally gave me a headache.
All right.
Stop paying bills.
Hey Bill.
Thanks to the left's,
you're welcome.
Thank you for listening.
I'm in search of the solution to the fucking bankers.
Oh,
in search of the solution for the fucking bankers.
I had a crazy thought.
What if the 99% just simply stopped paying all of our bills to major
corporations,
mortgage credit cards,
line of credit.
I'm not exactly convinced it's a solution,
but you can imagine the chaos even if half of the population did that.
Okay.
Uh,
just thought it would be interesting to get your thoughts on this.
Now I must get back to cleaning this grocery store.
Fuck you and everything you do.
I had to bring that back.
All right.
Uh,
I would,
if people used to say that I like that.
Fuck you and everything you do.
Um,
okay,
well here's the thing.
All right.
Um,
okay.
If everybody just didn't pay their bills then like
the whole thing would stop and the,
and they would put a lock on all the banks.
I mean,
all that money that they loaned out is,
that's your money.
That's my money.
That's regular people's fucking money.
All right.
It's not rich people's money then at loans,
unless they put it in a bank,
I guess.
Um,
yeah,
like that,
that would not work.
That wouldn't work.
And then they would just be like,
all right,
well then you guys have no more money and you know them.
They fucking the super,
the 1%,
I mean,
they,
okay.
They got like fucking wine cellars and shit and they got like,
you know,
they got like,
they like,
like they used to leave the,
the like woolly mammoth steaks,
you know,
they,
they get,
they got fucking food for days,
for months.
They can totally wait us out.
Um,
there's all,
the only way to fix all of this was human beings would have to have been wired
differently and we're not,
at the end of the day,
you know,
a lot of the shit that the upper 1% is doing,
I think all of us would also be doing if we had that opportunity.
It's just sort of natural,
you know what I mean?
I Dunno.
Okay.
Who would they go?
You know,
people don't handle power wealth.
My,
myself included.
Um,
that's an interesting thought.
I have no fucking idea.
I just wish that they would just,
they would just,
you know,
I pay my bills.
Why can't this country pay the bills?
Why can't you just keep,
you know,
why?
Why do we always got to be in this level of fucking debt?
They just keep going and going and going and going and going,
and they act like the,
to someday,
like the shit's not going to hit the fan.
Um,
Jesus guys,
king,
can you tell by these answers to these questions you're asking me?
They're just way beyond my ability.
Maybe this is why you do it.
All right,
lady Fan heckler question.
Uh,
hey there bill.
I'm a [inaudible] fan and I would like your opinion on a situation.
Amy Shu
and counted on her tour in Stockholm early on in her set.
A male heckles shouted,
show us your tits.
Okay.
Oh,
it's hilarious.
She heard it.
Had the audience points of the guy and shut them down pretty quickly.
What?
The few jokes.
All right,
good for her.
She also sit,
said if he yelled out again,
she'd have him kicked out.
Well,
literally five seconds later he yelled out again.
Yeah,
this guy's a class clown,
you know,
next person does that gets the attention.
And she did have him thrown out of the show.
Well,
it's her show.
She can do what she wants.
My question is,
at what point would you have a heck with thrown out or when have you had a
heckler thrown out is a great question.
I have no problem with their controlling the vibe at our own show,
especially when there were a ton of other audience members for whom the show
might have been ruined if the guy kept shouting.
Yeah,
they came there to hear her act,
you know what I mean?
Okay.
He got one,
show me your tits.
She fucking road with that and said,
hey,
you know,
it's not like,
it doesn't sound like,
you know,
unless she was talking about our tits,
which it doesn't sound like she was,
it doesn't sound like it had any context to what she was talking about.
If someone just yells that out,
then if it,
if someone's just going to just keep yelling,
fuck you,
blah blah blah,
or something like that,
then you know as a comic you could just stand there and just trash the guy for
the whole hour and still get paid,
but like the rest of the crowd is not going to walk away happy.
That has been my experience when you do something like that.
So anyways,
she continues.
She says,
I have no problem with to controlling the vibe at our own show,
especially when there were a ton of other audience members for whom the show
might have been ruined if this guy kept shouting.
However,
I've also seen you handle hecklers in your specials and shows without having
them ejected.
Um,
this case might be different senses.
Hex Is Haeckel was sexual in nature and as far as I know,
no heckler has ever shouted.
Show us your Dick.
Do you want stage?
Oh my God,
that would fucking kill me if somebody all day,
any who just curious is what you thought about at the video of the situation at
this link.
If you want to see it.
Uh,
can't wait for season two of emphasis for family and best of luck with your
upcoming special.
Thank you very much.
Um,
okay.
Once you're,
I dunno,
I think once you're at a level where you're selling tickets and it's your crowd
and everything,
uh,
I think you just do run your show how you want to have your show run.
I know that there's comics out there that say no heckling.
There's other people that don't give a shit about heckling.
I'm one of those people.
I don't,
mmm.
I don't mind.
90% of heckling,
you know,
it's that 10% where you just didn't want to be there or you're just completely
fucking Mike wasted drunk.
MMM.
And you're just there.
You're just gonna.
You're gonna.
Even if I get the better of you,
you're still just not going to shut up and you're just there to ruin everyone's
good time.
At that point,
I would say like,
listen,
and I would,
you know,
give the person the money back.
It's like I'm not trying to be a deck,
you know,
maybe next time or go see another comic.
But,
um,
I've only had to do that a handful of times.
MMM.
When I first did the opiate Anthony Show,
there was this guy I remember came down.
And,
uh,
he just didn't get it.
Like he came down
on the first show and was just screaming and yelling and screaming and yelling.
The whole fog.
It was,
it was crazy.
And um,
then he showed up
like two nights later again,
and he sat right down front and one of the waitresses overheard him.
I'm going to yell out the punchlines to all of his jokes
so I,
what I should have done was immediately say,
get that Guy Outta here.
Get 'em out of here,
give him his money back.
I'll take a picture with them.
Just get them out of here.
Cause I don't want to deal with this guy.
This guy's wasted and it's going to ruin the show for everybody.
And he was here two nights ago.
I can't come up with 60 new minutes and fucking two nights.
And he was deliberately going there to mess up the fucking show.
But the weird thing was,
was he didn't go there in a malicious way.
He thought it was funny and it was one of those things that was really in the
spirit of the opie and Anthony Show.
But this wasn't the opiate Anthony show.
This was a standup comedy show.
So it was an awkward thing and I had to get them out of there or else he was
going to fuck it up for everybody and he was fucking beside himself.
I mean we can,
we don't understand.
I love you though.
You don't understand.
Right.
So they ended up kicking him out classic way like the way a comedy club kicked
somebody out is they get them just be on the threshold of the door and
immediately turned a blind eye to the person like,
well that takes care of that.
Right.
Then they inevitably come back in,
which this guy did and I was selling cds.
This isn't long ago.
It was,
I was selling cds after the show and I look up and this is fucking guy again,
pleading his case with me and then he got so mad,
he goes,
I'm never come on one,
two year shows again.
And I was like,
good,
good.
The amount of stress and anxiety brought to me,
blah blah.
And then like the end of the night,
someone had broken the window out front of the club and I always thought it was
Sam.
I have no idea.
So,
um,
my thoughts on heckling is basically,
uh,
it's a part of the art form.
And I also think it's,
it's a part of the art form that makes it really cool.
But that's also,
I don't define the rules of it and it's just one of the things that I enjoyed
that always scared me in the beginning,
that I always thought was so cool about comics,
that people would yell at them and they could just handle them and then continue
on with their act.
Um,
and the way I look at it,
I say a lot of ignorant shit when I'm on stage and,
uh,
you know,
provoke people and stuff.
Like I can't expect them to sit on their hands the whole time.
And I,
you know,
I like it.
I actually enjoy when people yell shit at me,
you know,
to a point,
but if it's on topic,
Somebody Yell Shit of,
I always gorgeous say,
what'd you say?
No,
I'd go back and forth.
You know what I mean?
But uh,
yeah,
you know,
I dunno.
I mean it's,
it's kind of a part of being a comedian,
but I think after a while and once,
you know,
you said it was in Stockholm,
Sweden,
them,
and that's an important show.
You be going over there.
You're not like the other ones aren't.
But then here year in another country,
you want to make sure you have an a good show and right out of the gate if
someone comes in,
they come in at you like that.
Um,
they're testing you.
And I know a lot of it's going to be made like,
you know,
oh,
it's a sexting.
And you know,
that's not a heckle is,
it's this data now.
It,
it's,
it's the basic thing where it's like you're being tested by the crowd.
So what the comic has to do is throw the fucking hammered down or else the crowd
takes control the show.
And you're going to have a long fucking evening.
So yeah,
there's a million different ways to do it.
That's how she chose to do it.
It's her fucking show.
So then you go,
that's what I think.
I think however,
the,
however the comedian decides to handle it is,
is the way to handle it.
Um,
I dunno,
I just make it all the crazy,
some of the shit that people have said to me over the years.
Best one,
everyone's,
when I was at danger fields,
somebody yelled out,
Eh,
uh,
anything read in on stages that,
and yous said Faggot.
It's so they use like homophobia.
Okay.
For whatever fucking reason.
And uh,
I'll never forget that.
Heco because it was so like anything red and on stage it was like,
it was like worded,
like I was in second grade.
MMM.
But this guy was like,
I don't like the anger that was coming off of this guy and the group of people
that he was in with.
I knew if I engaged and there was no security at that club and I could not beat
up him much less him and two of his fucking friends.
And I just,
you know,
I liked the Mike stand where it was rather than wrapped around my Charlie Brown
heads.
So I didn't say anything.
I didn't say anything.
I,
I've had a,
okay.
You know.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Oh,
the memories coming back.
I bet I've had shit thrown at me.
So wait.
So dental philosophy,
one time I remember I was talking about working in a dental office when I was
younger and somebody in the middle just through dental floss like that would add
to the bit.
Somehow I had pissed off a woman in Tampa at one time and she threw a glass ice
at me.
Uh Huh.
So we can do a dinner roll at me,
had a lot of shit thrown at me.
MMM.
And then just every fucking thing I remember being on stage one time at the
Boston comedy club.
Yeah.
And they've used these two black women's sitting in the front and there was
barely anybody and there was late night and I was bombing and there was this two
black women in the front and one of them had put her head on the other girl's
shoulder and was pretending to sleep.
And it bothered me for about six years that cause I had a glass of water on
stage with the straw.
It bugged me for six years that I didn't think in that moment.
You know when you put your finger over the top of the straw and you keep the
water in it to come over and just then then let it go right on her face.
That's what kills you is a comic.
It's the thing you should have said or the thing you could've done afterwards.
Um,
but I really think that that to me that is one of like when I used to listen to
the Richard Pryor albums and stuff when I was growing up,
like one of the coolest things ever was,
you know,
listening to him going back and forth and is unbelievable special.
They did down in Long Beach where they had him go on early.
He just wanted to get out there and people hadn't gotten back to their seats.
Like,
I really felt like that interaction there,
it was like,
it,
it just put them in this zone and he just stayed in there for like an hour and
18 minutes.
And I think with that type of shit and the guy going up with the camera and
stuff,
I like no security.
I really feel like that.
Okay.
You know,
that interaction with the crowd,
you know,
that energy that they were giving them.
I think that that's what,
why that that specialist,
what it is.
So I'm not against tackling or anything like that,
but I,
you know,
every comic,
like I said,
you know,
if they feel like it's crossing the line,
he just feeling it's at that tipping point and I got the chop the head off
somebody sometimes you got to do that.
So good for her.
All right.
Emotionally cheating.
Uh,
Hi Bill,
a big fan of your stand up in the standup in the MLM podcast.
I wanted to get your advice on our relationship question.
I got married to my wife last year in September,
who I've known for 10 years.
Um,
prior to tying the knot at the start of this year,
my wife,
age 30,
admitted to me that she has been emotionally cheating.
Jesus.
She told you,
why did she tell you?
Okay.
As far as I know,
no physical cheating on me,
which started a couple months prior to us getting married with their 51 year old
coworker who's a divorcee with two kids.
What?
I was completely blind,
he said cited it's blind sided,
not sighted,
blindsided and in and in shock.
When she told me this about a month ago,
she told me she needs to go find herself.
Oh yeah.
She okay.
And it has recently moved out into her own apartment and we are separated.
Most likely headed towards a divorce.
That's why she told you,
thankfully we do not have any kids together.
My Dad keeps telling me to try and woo her back and work out our marital issues.
Even if I could do that,
I'm not sure.
I want someone who has betrayed Merrill Lynch trusts and scarred me in such a
way.
What do you think,
uh,
looking forward to season two is f efforts for family?
Keep up the good work and go fuck yourself.
Um,
I think you're in a great position.
You should stay there,
dude.
Fuck this.
Okay.
Um,
you've known him for 10 years.
She's 30,
so you met a real young,
she didn't get to go out and go do everything that she wants to do and uh,
yeah,
dude,
I would walk away,
you know,
if you guys are roughly the same age too,
you still got a lot of time and I would,
you know,
uh,
she did you a huge favor.
Just look at it that way,
dude.
Okay,
football season's here.
Get the NFL package,
you know,
start hitting the gym.
Just get on with your life,
man.
That's what I would honestly do.
And just,
you know,
get yourself in a great positive head space.
You don't have any kids.
She was upfront and honest.
She's 30,
she's fucking got a tongue hanging out about some 51 year old.
I Dunno,
that's fucking weird to me.
But I'm also a guy.
Um,
uh,
let it,
let it go.
Math,
you don't,
when you let a fish run on the line,
maybe tired out that just,
I would literally throw the whole rod and the water.
Just let that one get away.
Cut the line.
Fuck that.
Like I said,
um,
oh fuck that dude.
Go travel.
Go to Europe.
Go do something.
I Dunno.
Go.
Yeah,
you don't,
you don't need that shit in your life.
Thank God.
You know,
I actually felt relieved once I was reading that we're going to go to the end,
that you guys are going to get divorced.
You don't have any kids.
That's fucking great,
dude.
You're in a great position.
Don't listen to your dad.
He's probably old school.
It's a hell of a thing for me to say.
I don't know your dad,
but I just,
you know,
all people are,
they're always in a dead.
Work it out,
blah,
blah.
You know.
Fuck that.
Um,
I,
yeah,
football season,
yet
you don't get yourself a kegerator.
Just don't get fat.
You know,
like me.
All right,
the Unicorn.
Uh,
I'd love your feedback slash advice on this.
I recently met a very sweet,
smart and attractive lady.
Uh,
we've been texting back and forth for a few days,
getting to know each other and eventually got to the,
how many people have you slept with?
Question.
Okay.
I was upfront and honest and told her my number and when it was her turn,
she told me she was a virgin.
That's right.
She's a unicorn.
I never heard that expression,
but it doesn't stop there.
She went on to tell me she's never had a boyfriend.
Keep in mind she's 21.
Okay.
Don't get me wrong.
I'm old school and love that she's a virgin,
especially in this world of full of who was,
but it's still weird.
Um,
Jesus pleasing.
You just called every other woman out there basically who gives sex whores and
then she's weird.
All right.
We went on the first date a few days later and she lived up to my expectations.
She was hot,
smart,
funny,
and I had a great time.
My question is,
how is it possible that the smoking hot and seemingly perfect girl is a virgin,
let alone has never had a boyfriend?
I'm not complaining,
but I'm wondering if she's lying or if there's something that I don't see.
Well,
I mean I think you're going to physically,
you're going,
I think you're going to,
you know,
once she played softball and the ball took a weird hop.
Right.
Um,
wait,
whose story was that?
Oh my God,
that just popped into my head.
There was a comic from way back when.
I don't even think she does it anymore.
You said tell a story on stage about how she's playing some sport and it's got
hit and broke her hymen.
Um,
oh fuck.
I don't know what to tell you dude.
He said,
what's he saying?
You know,
I don't want to get into something with her.
And then finally she's a crazy or worse.
Thank you for the feedback and as always,
go fuck yourself self do what?
Just keep dating her and just see how it goes.
If she's fucking nuts,
walk away.
Okay.
If she is great.
I mean,
21 that's a little older,
but I mean,
it's not like 31,
you know,
26,
27,
that's when you starting to go like,
you know,
but someone could just be really fucking walled off,
really could've had overbearing parents or whatever.
Um,
I don't know.
She kind of really let you in and told something really intimate about herself.
Um,
you're,
you're in a spot where you're waiting for the other shoe to drop.
So if I was you,
I'd be asking myself,
why am I asking that?
Who did I date before this?
That's making me think that this is going to be an absolute shit show.
Now,
look,
I would be lying to you if I,
if I said that.
MMM.
You know,
if someone was smoking hot or something like that came up to me,
I would think at some point someone would have talked to her in,
to the rack by 21 nowadays,
but 21 isn't that old.
Um,
I say,
write it out.
It's a good enough situation.
See what happens.
And a,
if you're worried that she's a psychologist,
you know,
just don't get to fucking a,
crazy.
And like with the chick and then,
you know,
after a while,
I dunno,
maybe could actually have a conversation with her at some point.
Don't be so blunt.
Like how how's some fucking chickens hard is you never had a dick in her.
And we don't say it like that.
Just be like,
yeah,
I dunno.
You know what,
don't listen to me.
Don't fucking bring that up.
I,
but I would continue to see her if you having a good time.
I would continue to see her and um,
you know,
if you're really concerned,
I would just hide the knives in your kitchen the first time she stays over,
you know,
let's make sure the bats on your side of the bed.
It's really,
think this is going to be a problem,
but a,
that's if she even gets in the bed.
So we'll see.
Um,
all right.
That's it.
That's a podcast for this week.
I apologize for it being a little bit late,
but,
um,
you know,
whatever.
I figured most of you had the fucking day off.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on Thursday when I'll be in beautiful Charleston,
South Carolina.
All right.